ahia
vi informo che ho un amico che si chiama
giampiero che mi ha consigliato questo
gioco mi ha fatto spendere 4,15 euro per
acquistare giampiero se questo gioco fa
cagare in gruppo
no
ed a tutti i ragazzi perché sono video
io sono felice io ci siamo su 10 s è un
po strano non solo anche che di cosa
parli o che cosa sia però mettiamo
difficoltà easy e vediamo perché
dovrebbe essere una roba tv giochino non
parte no party come come si conferma
come si conferma la good bike
sarebbe bello aver speso dei soldi per
un gioco che cristo neanche parte va
bene go to the world
all'ex play slayer l'ora [ __ ] a
funzione call call joystick funzionava
bene
spiegatemi come funziona che non capisco
non so di cosa stiamo parlando
giampiero cosa mi stai fa cos'è devo
fare cosa sono in una paio devo servire
il tennis che colpisco non colpire così
colorati di queen capendo come cosa cosa
devo fare
qualcuno mi caga il mondo demoniaco
cos'è sta roba forte
l'ho colpito haiti pò squash ai devo
colpire la gente è però la parola perdo
subito ho messo modalità facile in
teoria ma solo rimasta modalità facile
però il giusto perché deve imparare io
sono un capitolo mi sembra carino
problema è che non capisco il senso
servire io la palla è bellissimo come ci
sono dei roghi rossi ampio male ogni
volta che i battiti pt dati far
scegliere il bonus va bene la vita la
vita di una vita va bene vai vai picchia
picchiare i fortissimi benissimo il
gioco da dove micheli è uscito jean
pierre ne adotta dove da che mi andro di
buco di culo riuscito ma spiega mi va
bene ok la bomba mamma mia visto che il
colpo ora kcal h
c'era troppa roba non potevo schivare
sono morto
guarda sono contentissimo me la sento
un'ondata sola difficile per dare un
senso sti 4 euro buttati nel cesso e la
madonna come come do come spiega
spiegami non ho bisogno che tu mi
spiegate come dovrei come dovrebbe
essere possibile
ma come dovrei farlo ma noi non si può
verso la palla non c'è più non vedo non
vedo c'è troppa roba c'è più roba che
nei compiti delle vacanze qua questo
casino qui ora cavalca aiuto che male eh
no avere del possibile ma lo sto almeno
quello colpito almeno una volta una no
vabbè giampiero ti vengo a cercare i
satelliti sei morto abbiamo cambiato
gioco cambiamo proprio completamente
genere questo è stato fatto da ondrej
spa drena ditemi voi se non merita
beware ed è una demo e io andrei su play
perché play fa rima con famiglie non
funziona non va non fanno i sigg roma un
gioco e bug o per favore di dio
grazie gesù in teoria dovrei riuscire a
guida ok perfetto
si parte bene si parte così ecco questo
invece l'ho pagato zero euro ed è già
meglio di come prima allora una persona
normale come fa a guidare e girare la
testa visto che posso guidare solo con
le regole frecce un pò dei controlli un
po strani però lo specchietto funziona
bene
a posto eccole le luci e amica vedo vedo
meglio senza come possibile
ok chiaro e tondo va bene allora siamo
in un cos'è sta roba qua ci sono dei
caravan posso uscire io non posso uscire
però ci sono i money guido una cosa che
in teoria non dovrebbe mai fare nella
mia vita però questo guidando possa
illuminare le cose illuminando vedo meno
di quando l'hanno indovino va bene cosa
dovrei fare in questo gioco non lo so
non ho idea
però mi fido di ondrej federboxe chi
come si chiamava ma devo fare drifting
in mezzo al nulla o che è perfetto
non datemi mai un volante in mano rega
perché potrebbero esserci dei problemi o
poi c'è qualcosa ma io posso uscire
dalla macchina no
insomma mi mettete degli edifici e cerca
fu
il carrello che dico c'è anche il fango
che schizza mi ha fatto benissimo ci
fosse qualcos'altro oltre la strada
sarebbe ancora meglio il suo gioco però
mi sta inquietando un sacco perché
dovunque vado ci sono sempre le stesse
cose
orco demonio
sono nell'oceano ma sono ancora vivo ma
siamo riusciti a uscire o forse me ne
sono andato rega ho trovato una strada
che bello ha finalmente una luce anarchy
ficcata vedi che non c'era solo quel
posto ok buongiorno anche sono
contentissimo di aver scoperto in questo
preciso istante che c'è una macchina
dietro c'è una macchina dietro si sta
avvicinando tantissimo cielo nel culo
ragazzi aia a maniago che cazzo sta
facendo cosa fa è scemo cosa vuole ma
chi di nunzio alla la pubblica
amministrazione non so cosa sto dicendo
ma che boero mamoli farci fare questo in
un alfabeto nova solo dire pezzo di kakà
mi chiamo vada via non ci siete usciti a
uscita cento città non c'è da 100.000
via via via che brutto mi ha fatto
perché la chiave ritrovare coraggio ma
chi era sta gente madonna che no ma dai
è orribile è stato bruttissimo noah devo
rifare troppo c della roba rossa ma non
capisco che non si capisce e prendi pre
libro c'è qualcuno me lo sono sognato
porca vacca che caga via via via via via
via veloce veloce questa macchina veloce
madonna che che cagasotto pure ecco lo
sapevo a chi c'è dietro
ahia ahia ha colpito di nuovo bastava
quei brutti che sono una persona che
guarda biglietto che vada schiantarmi
che ci andiamo a 630 martin garics
animals si insegue
ecco appunto sono andato a schiantare mi
succede però sono ancora in pista
tensione aiuto c'è gente che mi segue e
vorrei aiuto vorrei aiuto da qualcuno
polizia qualcuno vi prego c'è una star
qui a destra prima secondo no che ci
scherzavo scherzavo fatto una cagata
perché mi aspettano tonelli e degli di
riesce a [ __ ] perché quando quando
che fa in versione si fermano ti fottono
proprio michele andato un intelligenza
artificiale non indifferente va bene
parola e bastardi avete rotto mi chiamo
indipendente impegnino io il contrario
teste di culo vai avanti dai vai vai vai
avanti adesso va avanti in avanti allora
no no lo schiaccia mosto pedale è
magagna quello di diritto di precedenza
sai cosa voti a katy si schianto contro
il guard rail ha capito perché ci
andiamo a schiantare vai così cioè
animals chantorné ante porca vacca
no non è vero sono incastrato nona e voi
ce ne sono scesi subito stipe senti ma
vi investono ahi ahi ahi ahi a ben
vestiti non lo investiti non li ha
vestiti che male
sono stato ascritto a morte e decentrata
rispetto allo schermo questa cosa mi
crea disturbo però vabbè allora vive di
fare l'ultimo tentativo dove cerco di
seguire la strada il più possibile
perché ci sarà una fine dio mio
allora noi da bravi seguiamo il sentiero
non cadiamo nessuno
noi andiamo avanti ciao finta non c'è
nessuno nessuno vi sta seguendo
si chiama mi sentii il sentiero non
cerchiamo di farli forte andiamo dritti
dove arriviamo
perché poi la cosa che fate e che tutto
fangoso per terra ha capito quindi si
scivola che un piacere porca vacca non
so dove siano finiti secondo essere
incastrati da qualche parte è meglio
così se abbiamo la strada secondo la
strada meno male vai vai su una macchina
che si incastrata giu va bene non ci
fermiamo non ci fermiamo ci fermiamo via
via via via fontesecca fontesecca
bottega o arriva arriva un carro armato
e celustka su un carro armato come
minimo c'è il pirellone deprima piano
piano piano piano piano che ti minchi
tutta la macchina sinistra a destra ma
sai che ti dico sinistra
no che è successo
se però non tipo impantanare ogni tre
secondi di zio
più che kakà era un'altra macchina
incastrata sotto le macerie urgente
sentito la musichetta della gente dove
dove dove aiuto aiuto agli stati pagati
ma va a cagare un'ora che sono nel fango
eh va beh dovreste darmi una mano in
teoria ci vedete la macchina che ferma
spingete no vabbè ma ragazzi e
l'angoscia non nono abbassava stop basta
un angoscia come sono incrociate non
voglio più potente tenetelo ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ho giocato a
cose strane o molto strane ma forte però
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come
al solito se vi giornalmente mi piace
anche ai social scrizione se lo so che
ci siete vi noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]